just a few weeks before the holidays
worries over the omicron variant
continue the world health organization
says the strain is spreading at a rate
not seen with any other cova variant at
a global scale thus far
today new data from south africa's
largest private insurer show two doses
of fire the pfizer vaccine are less
effective against severe disease with
omicron than previous variants so the
big question how does this affect us
right how does this affect our booster
shot regimen moving forward bloomberg
intelligence senior pharmaceutical
analyst sam fazeli joins us now to talk
about how booster shots are likely to
match up against this new variant sam
always a pleasure to get your insights
the message is clear go get your
boosters right but is one booster going
to be enough against omicron and is it
too soon to talk about maybe a fourth
booster
um hi madison thanks for having me on
it's not too soon to start contemplating
the potential need for another shot
beyond the third chart
but that's a lot of that depends on
exactly what happens when you've had a
third chart so if we look at what south
africa taught us today and again i want
to stress that we have to
take any data that comes from a specific
country with a pinch of salt not because
of quality of data but more about the
fact that that's where the data comes
from it it refers to what the
demographics are if we take that defies
a bionic shot in general
provided a 70 protection against
hospitalization that's after two doses
if
the
scientists are right and the data is
right that with the booster you can get
protection against infection back up to
more meaningful levels of 80 90
then that follows that that hopefully
will also impact the uh third shot
risk reduction for hospitalizations
after that we'll have to see how long
that lasts and whether that wanes
whether there's another variant
do we are we dealing with for a fourth
shot i mean here are we dealing with
omicron plus delta delta alone amicron
alone a lot of unknowns there
yeah so what does that calculation look
like from a public health perspective
how do you decide whether to push people
to get more and more booster shots which
could potentially lead to increased
vaccine hesitancy versus just saying
we're going to lean into a um i guess a
medication model like with this pfizer
pill that we learned about from your
reporting today
yeah the fisa pill i mean you know what
is really nice to see there is once
as we saw the merck data we started all
worrying a little bit that that as
pfizer went goes from an interim
analysis at which point they should an
85
reduction in the risk of
hospitalizations and death
or death
to
full analysis it's gone to 88 so that's
gone the opposite direction to what
happened with the
american drug so that's great news
the point is they have said they'll make
about 80 million courses
this year um
that is a oh sorry 2022 we're nearly
there
that is a decent number of courses and
then of course you've got other
companies to which they have licensed
the the rights to manufacture for the
low to middle income countries etc so
that that's a lot of doses of courses
that would be useful in managing this
but let's not forget that's in people
who've already caught it we also don't
know yet how the drug works against
omicron i'm optimistic but we don't know
we also have to consider that catching
people in that five-day window isn't as
easy uh
as i think some people might expect
because you have different coverage of
healthcare etc and then of course last
point you have to make sure that you
know who you're treating and that people
take the drug
right of course what do you think in
terms of preventing infection in the
first place what comes first a new
vaccine that addresses the new variants
that we're going to continue to see
starting with omicron or an additional
round of booster shots which
course of action do you think comes
first
i think the current boosters number
three is critical in terms of preventing
the rapid expansion of of disease
but i have to say i'm not optimistic
that we will ever win the fight
of stopping all infections
the antibody levels that are required to
do that eventually wane and people will
still get
mild moderate disease the question is
we need to focus on severe disease and
once we've got enough data with the
boosters that we have do we need to keep
boosting people if we're already
controlling the progression of mild
disease to progress to severe disease
yeah on that point sam no one who i've
interacted with in real life but a lot
of people i know around the u.s have
tested positive
all of them are vax and boosted
it feels increasingly common at least on
a personal anecdote level that
people are testing positive with
breakthrough cases
to
what extent do you think that we just
sort of accept that we're all going to
get this eventually are we living in
fear of you know what we saw with the
first big waves of covid pre-vaccination
or uh
is it right to be really afraid of
getting sick with this because we just
don't know yet how bad the illness could
get
if you're not vaccinated i would be
worried unless you're 18 19 20 and you
think you're young and you can do but
even in those cases you get the because
it's not just up to the health status of
you it's up to your immune system and
they're not always perfect
so i look i've had a breakthrough
infection um a lot of people i know are
getting it so it's almost like saying
i've had a cold twice this year
i don't want to belittle this this this
issue because we have a lot of people
who are still not protected properly and
a lot of people are not vaccinated so
the right thing to do is to get those
boosters and please if people are not
vaccinated go and take the vaccine to
reduce the burden on our society
right so it's less that i need to be you
know terrified that if i see my double
vaxxed family members that i might make
them sick it's more uh a worry for
people who aren't vaccinated still
yes also also people who are communal
compromised who are very elderly so we
just need to understand all that a lot
better
over this next six to 12 months about do
we need to vaccinate them every every
six months or every year to protect
uh at that age group for instance
i also want to ask you about people who
have kind of gone above and beyond when
it comes to boosters at least here in
new york a lot of the jj
recipients for example went ahead and
kind of took it in their own hands to
get booster shots before that was pushed
through is there any
danger or caution to be had when going
in for
additional additional additional shots
particularly before it's recommended at
you know the federal health agency level
yeah i don't think the people who went
in for their
extra shots perhaps with an mrna vaccine
after a single shot of j j where were
wrong to do that because you want to
protect yourself and now of course
they're proven right while they're
waiting for decisions on how to boost
maybe a j and j shop wouldn't be better
for them
it's possible that jnj after an mrna
shot is better a lot of stuff to work
out still but but i would definitely say
people should not keep going back in and
buying extra shots because you actually
don't know
how this same vaccine constantly
behaves
and whether you're better off getting a
variant vaccine at some point in the
future rather than repeatedly the same
vaccine and pushing your immune system
to become fixated on this particular
so-called spike protein that you're
delivering with the community or
spikebacks yeah so where do you net out
on that sam should should people be
mixing and matching with their boosters
well i kind of had a natural mix and
match i had two a astrazenecas an
infection and identifies the booster so
i i every bit of data that i see the mix
and match especially
adenovirus plus mrna seems which is
really the vaccines that we have today
seem to be pretty pretty good at at
least inducing a good antibody response
what that means in protecting against
infection protecting against disease we
have to work out still
sam it's always a pleasure to be joined
by you you have such incredible insight
and context to give us on this virus and
we really appreciate it as we navigate
this territory year over year thank you
so much that was bloomberg intelligence
analyst sam fazeli joining us